- Lynn Margulis's theory
that evolution is a process
involving interdependency
rather than competition among organisms
differs dramatically from most biologists,
or no error.
So this is a little interesting.
Let's just think about what
the sentence is comparing.
They're comparing Lynn Margulis's theory
that evolution is a process
involving interdependency
rather than competition among organisms.
They're saying that that theory
differs dramatically from most biologists.
So this sentence
as it's constructed right over here,
it's comparing a theory,
it's comparing Lynn Margulis's theory,
it's comparing that to,
they're saying the theory
differs dramatically
from most biologists.
Well this is weird.
You're comparing a theory to people?
You're comparing a theory to biologists?
No, what you really want to do
is compare the theory
to the biologists' theory,
to the biologists' ideas.
So if you wanted to make this
make sense,
you would say, "differs dramatically from"
not "most biologists,"
you would want to say, "most biologists',
most biologists'"
and it's possessive,
"most biologists' theories,"
or ideas,
so you would cross this out.
Notice, you're comparing
Lynn Margulis's theory to,
and you're saying, "Lynn Margulis's theory
differs dramatically from,"
not most biologists,
but "differs dramatically from
most biologists' theories."
You want to compare Lynn Margulis's theory
to the other biologists' theories.
You don't want to compare
a theory to the actual people.
That's just--
you're comparing weird--
you're comparing, well,
it doesn't make sense.
You're comparing an idea
to actual physical, living human beings.
So, definitely error in Part D.